When you turn the one piece logo on its head,
just like Roger wanted to turn the world on
its head, you get a space craft as well as
a three-eyed skull.
The reoccurring theme of the frozen giants
tells us the secret of immortality behind
the enormous frozen straw hat in Marijoe.
And Drum island foreshadows what happened
during the void century, including Usopp's
snow Queen here that might show Luffy defeating
the hidden ruler of the world as well as the
strongest devil fruit there is.
This is only the tip of the ice berg of the
mega theory I'm going to share with you today,
hunting clues to reveal who Im, the mysterious
master mind behind the story of one piece
truly is.
I'm excited to say, that I think this theory
is even better than the last one I put out,
that a few of you found interesting.
However, these two actually don't contradict
each other at ALL.
Much rather, what absolutely BLEW my mind
when I found out, is that both smoothly connect
as part of one.
epic. mega theory.
So think of this as the best one piece theory
ever, Part II.
Now of course, I didn't come up with all of
this.
The REAL clue hunter is once again the Japanese
GOD of one piece theories Yuderon, who kindly
enough has given me green light to share more
of his awesome content.
宜しくお願いします.
I'm gonna be summarizing over 10! of Yuderon's
videos in a SINGLE one here.
I'm gonna cover all sorts of evidence here,
so please please remember that neither me
NOR Yuderon claim that every single detail
here is fact.
Just make up your own mind about everything
you're about to hear and who knows, maybe
you'll come to a completely different conclusion.
However, as he explained in my interview with
him, Yuderon's approach to theory-crafting
is based on HOW Oda actually creates and writes
the story.
You might want to get yourself a nice big
cup of coffee for this one.
Part I. Foreshadowing.
Factually, there is close to nothing we know
about Im from the story.
Just as you I was completely shocked and honestly
confused, that Oda seemingly just threw the
main antagonist into the story 900 chapters
in, without mentioning her even one single
time.
All we really know is that this person sits
on the empty throne meant to be held by no-one,
secretly ruling over the the entire world,
including the celestial Dragons and even the
gorosei themselves.
So, when I first stumbled across this 10+
video series on Im, I was genuinely confused
and skeptical, where you would even get all
that material on her character from.
But video by video and piece by piece I could
feel my mind being blown over and over and
over again.
Because as I realized, there has been foreshadowing
for Im, throughout the story, as early as
Syrup village.
Which in retrospect makes sense, because Oda
has planned his ending right from the start.
There are countless possible routes we could
start the theory from, but I think to have
a solid foundation to build on, the best one
is starting with all the foreshadowing and
symbolism for Im.
These are the 2 katakana characters used to
spell Imu.
And there are 2 very common theories in Japan
when it comes to the inspiration for her character.
The central wordplay here is 16, I Mu.
And when you take the two letters together
they form the kanji character for the Buddha.
Based on this, some people have speculated
that this is a reference to France, which
in Japanese is spelled as buddha country - for
whatever reason I guess.
So this might be a nod to the French Revolution
and especially the rule of Lous XVI, Louis
the 16th.
And indeed, as I explained in my analysis
of Trafalgar D. Waterloo Law, the French Revolution
and the events surrounding it, are without
any doubt inspiration for parts of the plot
and might very well hint at the past or future
of Im's reign.
The other alternative is going back to the
Buddha itself.
Here the number 16 is considered as a holy
number, that in one piece is referenced for
instance in Luffy ringing the bell at marineford
16 times or doflamingo's strongest attack,
16 holy bullets.
In general, there are 2 buddha-like characters
in One Piece.
There is Sengoku, who literally ate the Buddha
fruit.
And the second buddha in the story, any guesses?
It's no one else than good-old Tonoyasu from
Wano, who is seen as a Buddha by the people
of Ebisu town.
Now how do these two guys connect?
Both of them are former military leaders.
And both of them share the symbol of the maple
leave.
Sengoku wearing a shirt with them on it and
Yasu explicitly being said to have loved maple
landscapes.
And so the first major clue in our chase after
Im I guarantee will already surprise you.
It's none other than the worlds most badass
grandma, Dr. Kureha, who's name literally
means maple leaves.
As you'll remember form my interview with
Yuderon, Oda writes one piece according to
the principle two-sides-of-the-same-coin,
mirroring, twisting and inverting many elements
in the story in two places.
So, based on that idea, many characters Oda
has introduced at certain points in the story,
serve as foreshadowing to Im's true identity.
And we'll also look at people like Enel, Pudding,
Doflamingo and even Robin.
Especially Robin.
Now, if Skypea is the arc the key for Joy
Boy, and the ancient kingdom, as I explained
in part I, Drum island might be the most important
when it comes to Im and the secrets surrounding
her.
And Dr. Kureha has the closest connection
here.
Her name not only connects her to Im's name
through the Buddha, but the wordplay for the
chapter in which Im makes her big appearance,
908, is Ku Re Ha.
Her disciple Chopper, is a reindeer, which
in Japanese is called Junroku, Jun Roku.
And the volume in which we get to know about
the two is volume 16.
I Mu.
Kureha coincidentally is also the one who
first introduces us to the idea of inherited
will and the will of D. as well as revealing
Roger's true name to be Gol.
D. Roger.
And here, we also first learn about Blackbeard
and about Marijoe, where we literally see
the very first reverie taking place, before
meeting Im during the second one.
Chopper also plays an important role here
of course.
The deer and the maple leaf by the way, are
a strong playing card in the Japanese game
Hanafuda.
Now the big theme of Drum island is of course
medicine.
Yasuie was known as the hedgehog, which was
a famous panacea in ancient times, a medicine
which can cure all ales.
Chopper of course also wants to create a panacea.
This is because, all doctors in the country
have been monopolized by Wapol to control
the population, before being chased away by
Blackbeard.
Now however, Kureha sits in his empty castle
at the top of a high mountain overlooking
the rest of the people.
Does this remind you of anything?
As you've just figured out, this castle with
an empty throne and Pangea castle on top of
the red line are two sides of the same coin.
Here, Im is the one who sits in the empty
throne.
And so the idea here is that Kureha represents
certain traits of Im as well.
Something to do with medicine.
Dressrosa which also serves as a miniature
of the world at large, just like drum island,
has a ruler that monopolizes healing abilities.
Doflamingo's capture of Princess Manchery.
Dofi and Wapol, a former celestial dragon
and an aspiring one.
Oh!
And by the way, an important theme throughout
this video, is that Dofi and his crew all
represent certain traits of Im as well in
some way or form.
Now, Drum island is also inspired by Canada.
The small town is for example modeled after
the Canadian city Banff, I think is how you
pronounce that.
Canada of course being closely connected to
maple and maple syroup.
And sweets will also be very relevant later
as you'll see.
For Dofi's crew, the connection here is sugar.
Not only does she wear a hood and crown similar
to Im, but her abilities allow her to erase
memories, just as happened during the void
century.
And both, Kureha and Sugar are women way older
than they look.
Sugar being a 22 year old in the body of a
kid and Kureha being a striking 140, but still
going strong.
See where I'm going with this?
If these two characters are connected to Im,
that would mean that she is also a woman with
an unusually long life span.
How long?
How about eternal life long.
One thing that always confused me, was the
fact that the 20 kings, just like the 20 doctors
on drum island by the way, chose to abandon
their kingdoms and move to Marijoe.
I'm sure they had all the luxurious that they
could wish for there already and they even
had to give up their power over their nations
to new royal families.
What exactly is it then, that Im could have
offered a king, that they didn't already have?
Exactly.
I think one of the reasons that Im was staring
so intently at vivi, was due to the fact,
that she could not comprehend how her ancestors
could have passed on the opportunity to gain
immortality.
Just look at Cobra, the King of Alabasta and
how radically he has aged over the course
of just 2 years.
Compare that with the gorosei who seem to
haven't aged a day since we saw them 22 years
ago on ohara.
The contrast here almost feels deliberate.
The first time the Gorosei are introduced
is chapter 233, the wordplay here is Jin Mirai
Sai, a Buddhist! term meaning as much as until
the crack of doom or till the end of time.
Imu's first chapter 906 is ku on no risu,
the ideal of eternity.
To me, the reality seems to be, that in the
world of One Piece, Immortality has already
been achieved.
Don't you find it suspicious for instance,
that the world nobles, who love hoarding powerful
fruits and abilities, had no problem with
Law joining the Warlords?
That they apparently didn't care for his ability
to perform the immortality surgery?
I feel like they would definitely try to monopolize
and reuse this ability for themselves.
Instead, the person desperate for this ability
is none other than Dofi, a former celestial
dragon, who got taken to earth by his father
and denied reentry by the other world nobles.
If he was living a life of promised immortality
up on Marijoe, wouldn't it make all the sense
in the world, that he would resent his father
for taking that away and that he would want
his birth right back to live forever?
So, is the national treasure of Marijoe literally
an extended lifespan for its citizens?
The other national treasure we know of, is
that of fishmen island, coincidentally located
directly under the castle at the bottom of
the sea.
Two sides of the same coin.
The box on fishmen island contained a drug
that took away lifespan for more power.
So wouldn't it make sense if the national
treasure of marijoe granted more lifespan
in exchange for literally less power of the
tenryuubito?
Giving up their power and submitting to one
ruler.
The parallels between Drum island, fishmen
island and Marijoe don't end there though.
Two characters that mirror each other as well,
are Nami and Shirahoshi, you might remember
that as well from my interview with Yuderon.
They have the same look including the same
over proportional boobs, their mothers share
very similar personalities and deaths, both
were oppressed by fishmen and both locked
up for their abilities.
Sanji even calls Nami a mermaid princess in
chapter 69.
And on drum island we see Luffy climbing the
walls of the castle on the mountain, just
like fisher tiger did, to save Nami's life.
Could it be that he will do the same thing
again for Shirahoshi?
Fulfilling his and Joy boys promise to bring
her and the fishmen to the surface.
The other big clue is the suits of the celestial
dragons.
Yes, they do look like space suits and I do
want to talk about this in a moment as well.
What I want to focus on right now however
is the bubble that they wear whenever leaving
their residences.
Is it really only a symbol of not wanting
to breathe the Same air as the peasants down
below?
They don't seem so uneducated as to believe
that.
Well except charlos maybe.
But Mjosguard is not insulted when he loses
his helmet on fishmen island, he looks genuinely
scared to me.
So what if the celestial dragons actually
carry around air from Marijoe with them, not
because they need to rub it into everyones
face that they're not part of the Gucci Gang,
but because the air gives them their immortality?
Mjosgard even has a beard when we meet him
again, suggesting that he aged somewhat during
his time with the fishmen.
He even says that Otohime made him human.
Another thing we know makes fishmen island
special is that it is illuminated, despite
being at the bottom of the ocean by the roots
of the mother tree eve.
And so the idea that the top of eve goes through
the red line and up into marijoe is not exactly
new.
We also know that eve is related to the trees
on sabaody that create bubbles, that can then
be used to coat ships.
Funnily enough this is done by no-one else
than Rayleigh, someone who knows the true
history.
So if eve reaches all the way from the bottom
of the sea to the top of the red line, that
would mean that there could be a bubble held
in place underground on top of its leaves,
creating an artificial space similar to fishmen
island at the bottom, that allows the celestial
dragons to extend their lives, having to bring
small bubbles of it wherever they go to not
lose the airs effect.
Now, there are no clues as to whether it's
the tree itself that creates this effect,
or whether it just serves as a bubble.
If it DID have the effects of immortality
however, that would mean that Im, just like
Wapol, holds the monopoly of immortality in
the world, by enclosing eve into stone under
Marijoe.
So just how dr hiruluks cherry blossoms could
heal the hearts of the people of drum island,
could eve cure the actual bodies of those
on marijoe?
And tying it back to the Buddha and maple
leaves.
Remember this panel of dr hiruluks hair becoming
cherry blossoms?
Well Sengoku and Tonoyasu's hair do the same
thing as well.
And as we know, cutting down trees is a quite
common theme in the story.
Noland cutting down the holy trees of the
shandorans to save their lives.
Cutting down the giant jack to defeat Enel.
The literal tree of knowledge being cut down
on Ohara.
And choppers name literally comes from chopping
down a tree.
And if the straw hats had to cut down the
eve tree to end the immortality of the celestial
dragons, wouldn't that also fulfill the prophecy,
destroying fishmen island in the process?
And the symbol of the cut down trees brings
us to the next section.
Wow this is a long theory.
Let me take a quick br-...
No time for breaks.
I'll keep going for you.
Also make sure to subscribe.
Oh Yeah you should subs...
Get the hell out of here.
Part II!!
Im's Origin and History.
First, the giant jack and Enel.
We already talked about how important skypea
was as an arc in the last video.
And so Enel of course declaring himself god
and being taken down by luffy, the natural
enemy of gods, makes it really easy for me
to form a connection between Enel and Im.
Again two sides of the same coin.
So instead of eve we have the giant jack,
instead of marijoe we have the land of god,
you get the idea.
Enel is a fake god without wings, ruling over
the sky people and traveling up to the moon
to god's realm.
So if we invert this, does that mean Im is
a real god with wings, ruling over fake gods
after coming down from the moon from god's
realm?
Yeah.
But it's not quite what you think.
A likely inspiration for Im is the story of
Princess Kaguya.
If you watched Naruto, you're probably already
familiar with this.
But if your first reaction to this was the
same as mine - damn now they're gonna ruin
one piece the same way as Naruto - no worries!
It actually makes way more sense here.
Let me summarize the story as quickly as possible
for you.
One day an old bamboo cutter cuts shiny bamboo
and finds a kid in the bamboo.
The man and his wife raise the kid, who quickly
turns into a beautiful bamboo woman.
From then on out every time the bamboo cutter
cuts bamboo, he finds a gold nugget.
He's now a rich bamboo cutter.
The princess quickly is desired by everyone.
5 nobles come cause they want a piece of this
bamboo, but she doesn't want to marry any
of them and she gives them impossible tasks,
so they all fail.
Next comes the emperor and wants to merry
the bamboo girl.
This time bamboo girl is more interested,
but still doesn't want to marry him.
But they become pen pals and write lots of
letters.
One day, when Kaguya watches the moon she
remembers she's actually from the moon and
was sent to earth as A punishment or B to
protect her by the moon people, depending
on the version.
And so her pen pal the emperor sends guards
to protect her, but when the moon people come
to take the princess back, the guards are
blinded by a strange light.
Kaguya now announces that she must go back,
even though she loves all her friends on earth.
She sends the emperor a good bye letter as
well as the elixir of immortality, not too
bad, and one of the moon people places a feather
robe on her shoulders.
That moment she looses all her sadness and
compassion and love she had for earth and
she returns to the city on the moon.
The emperor then tries to send her a letter
by sending his army to carry it to the top
of highest mountain and burn it there.
Which is why Mount Fuji is literally the mountain
abundant with soldiers.
The smoke of the letter can still be seen
there to this day, only it's of course a volcano.
You already correctly guessed that im resembles
Kaguya.
The 5 nobles might represent the gorosei.
Bamboo is also represented by Virgo in the
donquixote pirates.
We even have the potion of immortality thrown
in there.
Kaguya returned to the moon, handed over the
potion of immortality and got her memories
erased.
Inverting that, Im came from the moon, took
immortality for herself and erased everyones
memories.
The feathered coat of course also connects
this to doflamingo, who literally has no compassion
for others.
His bird cage might then be a metaphor for
Im's control of the world, or maybe even the
moon, which might be an ancient weapon used
to create floods.
However, as we will see, Im is not actually
a citizen of the moon, as they prepared an
army against whoever invaded them.
Given that their descendants fought against
the ancient kingdom they most likely were
Im's enemies.
So, if not a sky person, who is Im then?
Let's return then to the idea of the celestial
dragons wearing space suits.
These suits, as well as the hoof of the dragon
are the main two symbols that we associate
with the nobles.
Now this may sound weird, but I'm gonna show
you a fresco from a monastery in Kosovo, which
is a world heritage site.
In the middle we see Jesus and on the top
right there is this guy here.
Now this was painted in the 14th century,
and I guess it won't surprise you to find
out that many have taken this to be the depiction
of a space ship by the unknown artist.
What interests US here however, is whether
Oda might have taken this symbol as inspiration,
making Im someone who came to earth from somewhere
else.
Because if you turn this symbol by 90 degrees,
you perfectly get the symbol of the celestial
dragons.
And an interesting detail I noticed as well
when looking at this, was the sphere with
8 orbs surrounding it, that we know from Alabasta,
Wano and Shandora.
But is Oda even into aliens?
Well, let me look at the first volume of One
Piece and... oh.
Now let's go down the alien route a bit more.
I mean, there are space pirates and all.
Oda mentioned in another author's note section
of volume 96, that when you turn 96 on its
head, you don't get 69.
And the idea of turning things on its head
are a pretty fundamental concept in one piece.
[Roger] Now this seems to be related to the
story in the manga.
But - could it be that Oda is telling us to
turn the literal Manga on it's head?
Well, let's try.
- Hmm.
So I think it doesn't take too much fantasy
to see the straw hat as a flying saucer.
With the moon above it.
However what is really interesting I think
is that the skull suddenly also becomes a
new face.
The nose flipped on its head becomes a face
with 2 eyes and a THIRD eye on top of it.
Well where have we seen that before?
The mouth of the skull then turns into this
elongated head.
But that would be ridiculous, who would have
a head like...oh right the symbol of the literal
space pirate we saw as well as Fukurokuju
in Wano.
Im also has this elongated shape.
So could her and Fukurokuju be of the same
race?
The three eyed tribe, that we now know exists,
thanks to puddings introduction.
But then Fukurokuju would also need to have
a third eye.
And he clearly doesn't..or does he?
Look at this patch of skin on his forehead.
This looks very suspiciously like an eye.
And we actually don't know what his other
eye-lids look like, since conveniently wears
sun-glasses.
Also to hide the fact that he has the same
ringed eyes as Im?
He even has this large wrinkle when he is
depicted as a young man.
And if Fukurokujo gets longer and longer with
age, wouldn't that mean that Im would have
had a lot of time to get really long with
age as well?
Which would also connect Enel to this, who
has the same buddha-like ear-lobes.
We already know that the three-eyed-tribe
is said to have unique abilities.
Shiva, the supreme god of Hinduism, also has
a third eye.
And it can also be seen on many Buddha statues.
And even in the west, there is the famous
eye of providence, which represents the all-seeing
eye of god.
In the world of one piece, the third eye is
able to decipher the poneglyphs.
And where do we meet Fukurokujo the very first
time?
Oh right!
In the poneglyph room under the castle.
Pudding is only half third eye.
So when the third eye is truly opened, does
it have the ability to see all things, like
clairvoyance?
And speaking of clairvoyance, that would fit
with Viola's ability, as one of the members
of the Donquite pirates.
Viola appeared to Sanji sitting on a chair,
again summoning the image of Im on her throne.
Mihawk, who has Im's eyes, also apprised the
first time sitting on a chair.
And funnily enough, the same is true of Pudding,
who we also meet sitting in a chair.
Same goes for alvida, who is able to rejuvenate
herself and also Hancock, who teaches us about
the mark of the celestial dragons and who
is able to turn people into stone.
The stone is actually another symbol closely
linked to Im.
In chapter 877, we see how Big Mom is able
to shorten peoples lifespans, while at the
same time Pedro blows himself up.
Two sides of the same coin with dr hiruluk's
death in drum island.
The word pay for this chapter is Ba na na.
Banana.
So what does a banana have to do with stone?
You'll like this one.
There is a very common type of myth in Asia,
called banana type myths.
Which let's be real for a sec, is the best
name of anything ever.
They all are a bit different depending on
the region, but all these tales follow the
same pattern: A god presented a stone and
a banana to a person.
The person choses the banana, cause at least
they can eat it.
However, the changeless stone is a symbol
of immortality, so if person had chosen the
stone, they would have become immortal.
By choosing the banana however, that rots
fast, they chose a short and mortal life.
Now if Im represents the godly and immortal
stone, who could represent the human and fast-lived
banana in One Piece?
Exactly.
Kaido.
I'm just kidding, it's Monkey D. Dragon and
Monkey D. Luffy, the two main threats to Im's
rule.
And now what is really interesting is that
in the Japanese version of this myth, the
banana is replaced by a flower.
And that brings me to probably THE most interesting
connection to Im sama of them all.
Nico Robin, user of the flower fruit.
Robin and Im are, you guessed it, two sides
of the same coin.
Im is 1 6, while robin is 6 1.
Robin's hometown, O'Hara, which has disappeared
from the world map, is the exact opposite
of the world's center, the sacred city of
Mariejoe.
On Ohara there is the tree of knowledge while
on Marijoe, there is Eve, who got cast out
of paradise for eating from said tree of knowledge.
Robin's protector is Dr. Clover, who is directly
connected to the Gorosei, who protect Im.
[...] And look at chapters 936 and 237, where
Robin literally uses a third eye.
Robin has the flower fruit, while Im is seen
in her flower garden in Pangea castle.
And Robin might also be the greatest hint
at Im's backstory.
She is the devil child.
So reversing that, Im sama could be seen as
the child of god.
While robin was feared and hated for her abilities,
Im might have been valued and cherished for
hers.
However, maybe just like Robin, people will
have tried to exploit her for it.
Another parallel is how Big mom used to hate
pudding and treat her just like Robin was
treated, until she found out about the three
eyed powers, when she suddenly became Big
Mom's favorite.
But she still was exploited anyways.
Remember what Saul shouted to Robin through
the fires of her burning home?
[...] He says Robin will not be alone forever.
So Im probably has been alone forever.
As far as we know, only the Gorosei even know
of her existence.
A person ruling in secret from a Thorne that
is not supposed to even exist.
And let's stick with Saul here for a moment
and look at the symbol of the frozen giants.
Because his introduction into the story was
very interesting in many ways.
A giant with the will of D., Saul is a reference
to the devoted Jew Saul, who one day was blinded
by a heavenly light and through a sign form
Jesus upon which he converted to Christianity
and became Paul.
Similar to this Saul converted away form the
celestial dragons to help the people of Ohara.
An interesting detail here, in English we
know him as Jaguar d.
Saul.
However Jaguar is not his name in Japanese.
Not even close.
It's Actually Haguwaru.
Haguwaru D. Hugging the world.
Which makes sense to me, because he's the
one who tells Robin that there are many gently
giants as well.
What connects Robin and her frozen giant to
Im then, is, you guessed it, the giant frozen
Hat deep under Marijoe.
Could this straw hat belong to Sauls ancestor?
A good giant with the Name D. And a straw
hat.
And what if I told you that we already had
that in the story?
Another frozen giant, is Oars on Thriller
bark.
And he literally takes on Luffy's personality,
when Moria puts his shadow in him.
Luffy, but a giant.
That's the symbol of the person who wore that
giant straw hat.
Which is why we see Luffy smiling at us, when
Im enters the room.
Now the big question is of course: Why did
Im keep it?
Shouldn't the D. who wore it be the natural
enemy of her?
Again, it's Robin that I think might give
us the decisive clue here.
Robin's defining character moment is of course
this.
[...] So what's the inversion of this for
Im?
I want to die?
Actually no, what is probably the case here
is that the inversion of I want to live is
actually I HAVE to live.
Im is immortal or more specifically not allowed
to die.
While she can grant the celestial dragons
immortality, she herself might have gotten
hers in a different way.
You've probably already heard the idea that
Im had the immortality surgery performed on
her.
Well, what if that person was none other than
our giant version of Luffy 800 years ago.
The reason why Im keeps this straw hat, is
because it belongs to the person who saved
her life, just like Robin was saved by her
giant and later by her straw hat.
The title of chapter 397, where Saul saves
Robin is 'To Reach the future'.
Not only Robin, but also Im?
And the other big clue that Im had the immortality
surgery performed on her, is chapter 660.
Here once again we have the symbol of the
frozen giants on Punk hazard.
The title of this chapter is 'The royal Shijibukai,
Trafalgar Law'.
This is where the symbol of the frozen giant
and the OP OP no mi come together.
The word play for this chapter is Ro Ru Mu
- Law Room as well as Memory.
Which is funny, because memory is symbolized
in One Piece by the falling of snow.
Snow by the way represented by Monet, Sugars
older sister.
And this will be our clue to what happened
to cause the void century.
A period between 800 and 900 years ago that
cannot be told, that has been erased from
memory and where any research is forbidden
by penalty of death.
T
his is exactly what happened to Ohara, after
finding out that a huge kingdom was destroyed
during these 100 years.
Me?
The motif here is most likely the French 100
year war.
Remember?
From the start of this video, 10 hours ago?
It was a civil war fought by the French lords
around 1400, and it was a war of territorial
disputes.
The French Revolution broke out 400 years
later.
And tis is referenced a.
lot.
in One piece, as I explain in my Law video.
But how do you erase 100 years of history
without killing every single person in the
world?
This is how Im did it.
Finally we can talk about Usopp and his snow
Queen.
An icy queen sitting on a throne.
Luffy's snow man by the way with a cape, three
eyes and a long head.
In this episode, snowfall first appears.
When the ship suddenly changes directions,
Luffy asks Nami if she forgot something.
And after all the chaos is over, Zoro wakes
up not remembering what happened.
Of course we have the snowfall on Drum island,
which represents Im as well as Hiruluks memeory.
Hiruluks words being [one dies when they are
forgotten].
Then, we have ash falling like snow in memory
of the burning merry.
We have another winter island with punk hazard,
an island forgotten by the world and in filled
with the memories of vegapunk.
And we have of course Ringo region in Wano,
which is also filled with memories for Zoro
and Hyori.
Notice how the snowball also always goes hand
in hand with destruction?
The snow man, doctor hiruluk, the merry, the
island of punk hazard, Wano.
The most interesting case of snow however
is probably during whole cake island.
According to Yuderon, chapter 900 might represent
900 years ago and the start of the void century.
[...]Canon balls falling like snow.
Big Mom's musical telling the story of the
destruction of the ancient kingdom on Jaya.
Chapter 901, Even if you die, don't die, represents
the swallowing of Laugh tale and the escape
of the whale.
Basically how laugh tale vanished from Jaya.
You know like the little island inside lagoon
that crocus lives on.
And chapter 902, End Roll, is the end of the
war and the erasure of memories.
The word play here is 'for eternity'.
Here, we see pudding falling in love with
Sanji and kissing him, but not having the
courage to let him know, so she cut out his
memories using her power.
Pudding, also a member of the three eyed tribe,
of course representing Im here, and how she
took away the worlds memories to create the
void century.
And will you look at this.
Coincidentally, it is snowing cotton candy
in this episode.
Chapter 903 is Luffy becoming an emperor of
the see.
The sea being uni in Japanese.
Luffy the emperor of uni and enemy of the
gods, vs the godly emperor imu.
Now the image of the snow queen is most likely
connected to the story by Hand Christian Andersen,
which actually has little to do with the Disney
version.
Basically, there is an evil troll that creates
a distorting mirror.
A piece of that mirror gets stuck into the
heart of a boy, so his personality changes
and is taken by the snow queen.
His friend Gerda sets out to find the boy
and heals his distorted heart with her love
and tears.
All taking place under the beautiful northern
lights.
The important things to take from this story
that inspired Oda are snow, memory, the queen,
light and the mirror.
In 902, which represents the erasure of memories,
not only did big mom , the queen, pudding
the memories and snow appear, but also Brûlée,
the mirror.
Also we have Kureha again as the snow queen
in her icy castle.
And there even appears a talking reindeer
in the story.
Another character connected to mirrors, light
and memories is Django, who is on the cover
of chapter 145, where hiruluk says people
only die when they are forgotten and blows
himself up.
There is a literal mirror ball and light.
Django first appears in chapter 25, titled
800 lies, for no apparent reason as well.
In other words, I believe that the way Im-sama
and the other Celestial Dragons manipulated
memories and created the 100-year gap 800
years ago, was by covering the sky of the
entire world in white and then emitting a
strong light, used the reflection of that
light to manipulate peoples memories.
Just as the strong light in the story of Princess
Kaguya after which she lost her memories.
We can see this represented at marineford
as well.
Sengoku the buddha, aokiji the snow, Kizaru
the light and akainu the creation of the red
line.
The word play for the void century is 989.
So looking at 989, what might represent the
void century?
The answer is Franky or to be more precise,
his radical beam.
Unlike before, it explicitly takes on the
shape of a snow flake here.
And the first time light was referenced in
a title was 850, where we see smoker and a
snake in the snow.
It's also the chapter Pudding reveals her
third eye and evil intentions for the first
time.
Im used snow and light and some unknown power
to erase the memory of the world.
And thus created the void century, now only
encrypted on the poneglyphs.
Part III.
Imu's devil fruit.
Now the last riddle to solve is the question,
what makes Imu so powerful that she can rule
the world, next to her three eyed powers?
Does she have a devil fruit?
Yes she does.
And it's an AWESOME devil fruit as well.
In fact it has something to do with water,
but it's not what you think.
It's actually a mythical devil fruit.
The initial hint we get for this is actually
the alabasta saga.
It's the parallel arc to Dressrosa, and so
it was no big surprise for me that it also
had something to do with Im.
The Saga is about Crocodile trying to steal
the country to acquire the ancient weapon
pluton by depriving the country of its water
supply.
The purpose of the Baroque Works organization
is to realize an ideal world, and just like
no-one knows about Im, no-one knows the real
identity of Mr. 0 aka crocodile.
Spoiler alert.
Crocodiles weakness is water, so if we invert
this, it makes water Im's strength.
Chapter 212 when natural rain finally falls
on alabasta again also has Octopako on its
cover, sitting on a chair with three eyes
open.
The same pose as Nami on the cover of volume
11.
Nami, who was called a which in the arlong
park arc, who controls the weather, just like
im might be able to control the rain.
Arlong also having 16 as a wordplay.
However the idea of controlling water is not
only limited to alabasta.
Fishman island, the opposite of Marijoe, has
the martial art fishmen karate, that allows
the control of water, currents and even moisture
int he air.
So Im's ability being very powerful it is
likely that she is able to control any form
of water, including that in the air or even
in the body of living things, possibly making
it possible for her to grant immortality.
As you know there are weaker and stronger
versions of certain devil fruits out there.
Im's fruit would then be the more powerful
version of Monet's Snow fruit and even Aokiji's
Ice fruit.
Because if you can control the moisture in
the air, you can also freeze things.
You can even create storms and other weather
patterns.
The most powerful fruit in the world.
The concepts of water and rain are closely
tied to her character.
Imu in reverse means umi.
Im's 16 is also the wordplay for rain a me.
The wordplay for water, Mizu is 32, in chapter
32 we see momo's dragon on the cover and the
title is Disaster.
And since ame also means candy in Japanese,
we have the link again to sugar and the entire
whole cake island plot.
Rain, other than snow almost always has a
destructive symbolism in One piece.
Diamante rains thorns and iron.
Also there is Doflamingo's white waves.
We have Shiriu of the rain, the bombardment
of enies lobby being compared to rain and
of course evening shower Kanjuro.
And there are a endless chapters that have
various wordplays relating to Im that have
to do with water.
I'm not gonna bore you with all of them now
though.
The real question is, what is the corresponding
chapter to Im herself.
Chapter 16.
Its...a chapter about...buggy's crew?
Oh damn maybe the wordplays don't work at
all.
Only that we're of course not talking about
Im but Im-sama.
Im sama is 1 6 3.
And chapter 163 has it all.
A big full moon in clear sight.
Luffy wanting water.
Vivi, the queen, hiding herself and her forehead.
Cobra stating that the weather is gods work
and of course Arubana which has Hana, flower
in it.
The other chapter that fits is 56, where we
first hear about the all blue and that features
the notorious pandaman.
Oda's backstory for pandaman is that he is
a demon superhero who resolved to become strong
because when he told people that he saw Princess
Kaguya, they didn't believe him.
Rings a bell right?
And for chapter 563 we have chopper eating
cotton candy with some birds.
Cotton candy in Japanese being wata ame, rain
again.
As you can see, we have gone full circle back
to chopper.
And the birds are important as well.
Notice how many of the characters that embody
Im have a bird theme?
Robin, Monet, the snow bird on drum island
that was linked to mariejoe.
Hawkeye.
Doflamingo.
You get the idea.
So we have the symbol of a bird, of water
and of the third eye.
And there is one mythologic creature that
unites all these features.
It is associated with youth, femininity, Buddhism,
the third eye in hinduism, water manipulation,
has wings, dances like the dance powder and
are often compared to gods or angels.
Just like chopper has the a human model devil
fruit and Sengoku has one, Im has the the
human human fruit model Apsas.
The Celestial Water Nymph.
If you want to fully understand how this crazy
theory came together, you have to watch my
interview with the theory master Yuderon himself
here!